having find success with its previous
company of heroes two standalone
expansion the multiplayer only Western
Front Army's relic is looking to repeat
the trick with Ardennes assault only
this time it's all about the single
player 1944 is the year and the Battle
of the Bulge is the world war two
conflict at the heart of the game not a
historically accurate retelling of those
events though but rather a chance of
players to influence and change the
events of that year so while the
campaign is set across a map of Belgium
split into different regions each
representing individual battles for you
to fight and conquer when a skirmish in
the region and it's under your control
for the rest of the campaign
for the impact of dismantling German
positions is felt elsewhere taking a
particular region can cause enemy
reinforcements to populate an adjacent
area which in turn forces you to rethink
your original strategy for something
more reactive less those fresh dangers
get out of hand replayability is the aim
here with the emphasis firmly placed on
multiple playthroughs creating new
conflicts and problems it works rather
well in part thanks to the additional
complexity that comes by of featuring
three different companies support
recognized and airborne there are unique
abilities for each but what's important
is to stay aware of their health and
experience levels using a specific
company in battle is both a risk and a
reward and that it's possible for them
to die and take no further part in the
campaign but then winning engagements is
the only way to improve their skills
it's all very well and good saying that
you're going to concentrate on making
your mechanized company as good as it
can possibly be but if they end up being
wiped out your remaining support and
airborne units are going to find it very
tough going if they've never been in
battle before like it or not presuming
you're playing on a challenging
difficulty level all three companies
must be thought of as a single larger
entity we're stronger together after all
this becomes especially poignant when
deciding which areas of the map
attack with each company the three move
around the map independently of one
another feeling it's possible if you're
not thinking ahead for one to get cut
off from the others and potentially
become surrounded by the Germans here
you have a tough choice to make does the
greater goal make an attempted rescue
worthwhile or would you be better off
continuing with the original plan and
hoping the besieged company can make
that alive skills wise support company
specializes in explosives airborne is in
its element when positioned behind enemy
lines and mechanized is like a
combination of the two requiring equal
parts courage and contemplation while
there are plenty of welcome changes to
companies the cool rules dictate and
combat remain largely the same as in
Company of Heroes 2 which is no bad
thing capture points must be controlled
to earn resources that can be spent to
improve and buck your forces while
staying behind cover and intelligently
taking advantage of high ground and
differing terrain conditions makes it
incredibly difficult for the enemy to
catch you unawares Company of Heroes 2 s
combat was skillful and considered an
Ardennes assault as a great job and
adding to those fun mechanics and does
so without damaging what was so great
about them in the first place
expansion it may be but from what we've
seen so far plenty of new stuff to get
excited for when Ardennes assault close
to PC on November 18
we've done it pleases ours
you
[Music]